hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca I'm monster on a world again and
today we're gonna be showing you how to
get the new Durrani Craig or downy Craig
however you want to pronounce it the new
dual Boyd's that came with the Autumn
Festival that just released about an
hour ago so with that let's get started
with today's video so basically to start
off you want to be doing the quest
called where the Sun meets the moon and
all you want all you're gonna be doing
is fighting a pukka pukka and a toby
Qaddafi in the ancient forest they're
not tempered so this is going to be a
very easy fight of course like I said
they're both super easy but fireworks
the best if you don't feel like one
wasting time to switch weapons for the
different elements and stuff just use a
fire weapon it's basically the easiest
way to get this done
after you're done it you'll receive the
Downey Craig tickets to use at the
smithy D Downey Craig dual blades are
actually pretty damn good compared to
the other dual blade weapons that also
have sleep element the highest has less
damage but more affinity so depending on
what you want to rock you can use this
in your build or not personally to me I
like to be using elemental weapons and
element weapons it's just the thing that
I like to use but that's just me
this could be their completely different
for you so if you do think this is a
good idea definitely put that in your
bill if your sleep user especially with
the dual blades and regardless these are
actually pretty cute they're actually
just the little birds stuck to your
weapon and just smack mount monsters
with little birds I think that's really
cool let me know what you guys think of
these weapons if you're personally gonna
be using this in your build if you use
dual blades or anything like that or if
you don't like the weapon at all just
let me know in the comments below what
that guy's it's going to be the end of
the video today hope you guys did enjoy
we guys did learn something new of
course like the V if you do enjoy a
subscriber if you're new I cover the
solo gods a monster hunter world as well
as some tips and guides like this as
well
so that if you do enjoy that than
definitely consider subscribing and with
that I like the view can do enjoy and
with that my two most recent videos will
be on the screen if you guys do want to
check that out with the guys hope
ever-greater day thank you for watch the
video and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]